our classic car expert christophe bauer
is tooling around the northern italian
province of Trentino in a porsche on the
virtually empty roads of the plateau of
lava oniy he finds it hard not to fall
in love with a 911 Targa the porcelain
if Christophe says the Porsche 911 is
the sports car par excellence now as
ever its shape is immediately
recognizable your target stands for the
removable roof which normally sits
between the windshield and the roll bar
the Targa's roll bar was the brainchild
of company chairman ferry Porsche and
his son Ferdinand Alexander Porsche who
designed the 911 the roll bar was made
to protect the convertibles inhabitants
in case the car flipped over
[Music]
but its appearance drew mixed reactions
some even joke the targets brushed in
Rasta steel rhobar reminded them of pots
and pants and had them reaching for
their dishcloths
still over a quarter of the 911s
produced at the time were targets
[Applause]
unfocus that christophe says that at
first the targa was a quick fix the US
was Porsches biggest market then and
still is today but in the 1960s an
ambitious lawyer named Ralph Nader
launched his unsafe at any speed crusade
to get dangerous cars off the roads
especially convertibles so Porsche
quickly developed a safe convertible
with a roll bar and the Targa was born
Christoph feels the name was well chosen
it harks back to the Targa Florio
endurance races held on Sicily and
target is an old word for shield clever
huh the Targa has been rolling off
assembly line since 1965 unlike its
predecessor the 356 which had always
been available as a convertible the 911
only came as a coupe a when the model
was first introduced in 1963 one that
knowing on things tough tells us Porsche
started fitting the target with
panoramic glass rear windows in 1969
before that there was a plastic one that
zipped open the problem was you often
couldn't shut it again as the plastic
shrunk at low temperatures he says this
1972 model has a different weak spot to
achieve a better weight distribution the
oil tank was mounted just ahead of the
rear axle and filled here you can guess
what happened some owners or gas station
attendants filled it with gannis causing
major engine damage just a year later
the oil tank lid was history
it's harmonious shape has made the
portion 9/11 one of the world's most
beautiful and timeless sports cars the
target roll bar and the wraparound rear
window continue the flowing lines seen
at the front with a centrally placed
tachometer wings that are visible from
the driver's seat an ignition to the
left of the steering wheel the targa
boasts all the classic features of a 911
not to mention its rear engine a Porsche
trademark
[Applause]
this 911 T was the weakest variant of
the 6-cylinder 2.4 liter engine which
was fitted into the models starting in
1972
Christophe says these days 130
horsepower sounds more suitable for a
family car than a racy sports car but
not here as this is a Porsche after all
the engine revs willingly and
accelerates quickly going from 0 to 100
kilometres an hour in just 10 seconds
and it can hit 200 km/h so you can still
drive it with confidence today even the
highway police appreciated the cars
combination of fresh air and driving
performance the hundred thousandth
Porsche ever made was a 912 target
equipped with a blue light for the
German police
[Music]
as a Cristo says fans swear the 911s
handling is second to none the rear
engine delivers endless amounts of
traction making frills like power
steering and ESP superfluous he calls it
the perfect recipe for endless driving
pleasure but compared to modern 911s
cornering stability is limited so when
you enter a curve quickly and suddenly
take your foot off the gas the rear end
can slide out then you must quickly
counter steer to get back on track but
such driving challenges and the
inimitable throaty sound of the
air-cooled boxer engine are the
ingredients that have made the classic
911 such a success story
[Music]
then whenever Christoph says the 911 is
the most successful supercar of all time
like no other it balances sportiness
with everyday practicality and with the
911 Targa Porsche added a trend-setting
security concept
he says the cars the perfect synthesis
of hedonism and rationality of open-air
feeling and safety and that makes the
911 Targa a true milestone in automotive
history in 1982 another Porsche started
to give the Targa a run for its money
the 911 convertible after a 16-year
break the sports car maker returned to
making open top vehicles without roll
bars still the Targa remains and
Porsches lineup to this day
you